when we talk about unforced errors for
Donald Trump the sort of unprompted and
pointless and easily demonstrable lies
strike me as some of the most damaging
three to five million people voted
illegally Obama wiretapped me I had a
record inauguration crowd all these
nonsense claims that are easily debunk
oval and Trump has now made another
laughably silly assertion he's been
saying for a little while now that no
president has passed more legislation
than he has but he went even further
yesterday now Trump says he has signed
more bills through the legislature than
any president ever in the history of
presidents check this out in just a few
months and moments I will say what we've
done over a short period of time and
what we're going to be doing over the
next six months will be incredible
we signed more bills and I'm talking
about through the legislature than any
president ever for well Harry Truman had
us and now I think we have everybody
Mike I better say think otherwise
they'll give you a Pinocchio I don't
like those I don't like Pinocchio's yeah
it's hard to figure out what Trump even
means by this but the sort of primary
thing that I'm gleaning is Trump might
not know what a bill is that's the big
revelation from the video and the truth
is Trump is behind the previous six
presidents in terms of bills passed
during his first six months half of the
things that Donald Trump signed were
totally inconsequential minor and
without any controversy they still count
but Trump is still wrong and as usual
one of the traits of pathological liars
is that they lie unprovoked about issues
which no one is even really expecting
them to try to lie about right like the
number of people at your inauguration
nobody was expecting Trump to try to
deceive about that and he comes out and
unprovoked claims he had record
inauguration turnout so I think number
one it's pretty likely Trump doesn't
really know what a bill is it's also
possible he met restaurant bills from
all those dinners where like with the
MIT Romney dinner where they had turtle
soup and all sorts of other stuff maybe
he means that they've been
hang restaurant bills or something like
that maybe he thinks signing executive
orders counts as passing bills I don't
know I think you're right it's not
really even an indication on how well
you're doing as president because what
matters is the merit and how good the
bills are and you'd think he'd be able
to do a lot more because he does control
both houses of Congress but as you
alluded to also FDR and Truman were able
to pass more in their first 100 days
than Donald Trump has thus far well you
the main point the first point is the
big one right which is this is obvious
to many of us but maybe not to Trumpets
success isn't measured by how many
things you sign it's what you pass that
matters and maybe Trump thinks like the
memos are bills since every time he
signs a memo there's a whole ceremony
and Trump might must think wow I mean
there's a whole there's a whole
commotion around what I'm doing maybe
this is a bill of some kind I don't know
and to the point about what the merits
of what he's passing he's passing a lot
of things that are really really bad
like for example he signed a joint
resolution which got rid of a rule that
tried to prevent people with serious
mental health issues from buying
handguns they got rid of that that's not
exactly an accomplishment that I'd be
bragging about but this definitely
appears to be diagnostic you know it
genuinely seems like he can't help
himself from lying which is one of the
signs he has to be the largest liar when
it comes to politicians in the United
States PolitiFact scorecard of him rates
met 69% with false statements and
obviously like that's not the best
indication because those are just the
things they choose to look into yeah but
his rate of lies is far higher than any
other politician that I could think of
he lies big-league I mean that's that's
really the only way I can think of to
say it